on sait qu'avec ma tension va contrer
deux mecs à quoi vous dire qui tu
pourrais pécho antoine m2a d'accord
alors attention c'est parti
eux qui tuent ken regarde emmanuel
macron jean michel maire compte métier
quand même alors ça sur la dernière fois
liane foly la fessée emmanuel macron
qu'à gagner au bout du bout ouais et
pourquoi compliquer ma l'air compliqué
parce que j'adore jean michel baylet
qu'il est c'est un gentleman dans la vie
cette photo il est pas génial mais ça
mais en même en vrai il il est vraiment
pas mal et macron c'est un type
intelligent équipe alors sexy mais je
pense que je m'amuserai plus avec jean
michel et jean michel mr ouai je crois
les marins je pense qu'on peut s'amuser
avec jean michel aulas plus allaiter de
baiser avec des pics ont le dos bloqué
au top
[Applaudissements]
s'excuser de la cuisine on a entendu
enfin auprès de toutes les tous les
français tu as leur bloquer donc jean
michel maire reste attention jean michel
maire ou arthur h jean michel ah bon non
parce que j'ai travaillé avec arthur
donc appartement où je travaille moi
c'est à dire notre avis c'est le jour
qu'a lui tout seul à salé travail par
jean-michel wales amis c'est jean-michel
reste pour l'instant il bat iba art sur
emmanuel macron pas mal pour jean-michel
la passion alors quand même mal à ça
devient plus compliqué à alasay bien qu
alors là il faut choisir alors
magali bon à l'ayguade wec haddaoui la
jason statham qui s'essuie dizaine ouais
quoi johnson en direct ah ouais direct
je suis sûr que sous le feu la glace en
finance ou le sous la glace le feu enfin
peu importe je sais pas de couilles
trois raisons de voir la vie du bon côté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va vivre les passages du lieu à
tokyo à une affaire statham ou nicolas
sarkozy ça reste un an piedalloues jason
attention jason statham où harry
roselmack à dieu tous la vingtaine de
noms
[Applaudissements]
plus important pour une femme les
sentiments ou les cm s'est fait les
dents sur bon dans l'évangile va mettre
à table ou bien leonardo dicaprio a à ça
alors là les welsches indien petit doute
quand même il est un peu jeune pour moi
petit caillou parce que moi j'aime bien
les vieux ou salés ouest
mam et et fabien lecoeuvre je crois que
phase compliquée parce que je trouve
très très sexy
alors maintenant mais je rassure statham
m dames je suis à fond sur ce type là
attention ça va être très dur je pense
que je sais que nous avons fait des ouf
et je crois au plus savoir qui a eu un
truc entre vous et le gala non je vous
parlais que c'est vrai donc là benhaim
vous dirai la vérité au boudin
[Applaudissements]
non mais ça arrive c'est donc chez sun
attention on va monter en puissance
vas-y berne et de bâle j'adore pierre
niney alors à la la la la
j'adore pierre niney parce que je trouve
brillant drôle métro shalom est trop
jeune je restais sur le viol alors est
le dernier et le dernier est dernier
bébert le fromage est donné
[Applaudissements]